wie mona mitten drin weiß nie etwas mini
verschläft mobilität landet malz mit dem
knie
und der ort ist absolut barockzeit
kinderkrebsstation erwischt
das sieht zwar york
[Musik]
der züchter hat mich sehr bewegt
mit mona vetsch ich muss sich zu immer
weiß hellblau ist funktional ja
geschlossen zieht er an wie immer wieder
gefragt was ist deine sheen wurde nie
getroffen haben muss und martina oder
ganz am anfang standen dann wieder bei
kinder sich mit heftiger moment
[Musik]
es gibt eigentlich nicht anders übrig
macht ja entweder manchester oder die
andere varianten ist einfacher zu herz
nicht den dort zum segel osten wenn im
stade erkranken oder die scheinbar
fußball fehle werde aber den strich dass
in die zukunftspläne gemacht
[Musik]
aber unsicherheit bleibt
und dann bin ich bin fix ii trainerteam
data alles abverlangt
[Musik]
und das ist der findet uhr ab essen und
die familie mit ihm vor zwei jahren riss
keine klärung sap station vom fiz der
film erscheint martin lesch ihres lebens
das ist mona mittendrin update
bürger in kommt und thurgau
ich bin weg zu finden und das biz liegt
vor dem video sei
[Musik]
sie werden
ich bin ganz anderes grundstück und
schwer zeichnet von der network riege
von der emo
die ältere immobilien die eigentlich
organisierte stark und nachteile oder
wie man jetzt die zeit wo man im spital
sind die suche ich bin vom kritik da um
ihm kritiker immer da wenn ja so ja vor
allem ich als kühl das ist auch wichtig
für die firma grenze um erträgliche sie
häufig intensiver ausgewachsene bilder
junger körper memos halte bin
vorbereitet für die flaggen der junge
den kontakt krebsmedikament
weil die einmal filme kennt genau hat
der tarif für gesunde sind substanzen
gesundheitsschädigend sind einfach eine
einzige wirkliche oder wirtschaftliche
tun oder berechtigt steht
und dann habe ich gehört war feucht die
meisten
[Musik]
arminia wieder jeden tag
ich habe druck es geht um richtig gut
ich habe meine schwierig oder so mit dem
alltag kurz um wirklich gut gott zum
glück gut aber wenn man so legt diesen
vorgang ist wirklich ein riesiger
unterschied so cool dass ich so budig
zog sie würden jede frau das gefühl
immer neue therapien
[Musik]
wenn du immer gemacht so baldmöglichst
rückstand in der vitrine dass ich im
spital empfehlen sie es ganz große ziel
die zweite cross alle zwei wochen findet
der unterricht im wald statt
das ist super für die vielen unterwegs
traum
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die wasserstände auf der welt ja da habe
ich meine spieler bereit
ich hoffe dass da hinten freunde im
alter zu wenig gemacht ja ich bin da ria
gleiche freundin immer richtige feel
about als charakter
aber es ist auch im spital
wenn ich meinen kopf dafür
die frage wieso essentially ziehen geld
da ist fußball so darstellen wie man
eigentlich nach 19 ii braucht und warum
er schon dafür vor allem die unglaublich
und in walldorf das gefühl während er
lange zeit im spital liegen teil von der
klaus blieb was ich seine lehrerin
wichtig sie
er hat den afrika wo er quasi sie sich
bilden stieg sie also er ist immer
präsent sind es war im spital zu
scheinen die alljährlich kam für ihn ja
auch immer taxiverband hinter hat aber
der vorwoche für den markt und die
wünsche sind genervt auf dem tablett
sind dank sich geglaubt hat ein händler
er den hang töne mitarbeit bei diesem
film halt auf die schlechte phase sieht
was im film so schlecht gegangen ist für
sie eine klassenkameradin schon wieder
weg nicht aber für die familie
darwin hat krämer schlecht vertreibt
lang hat man ist richtig dass es gott
ich das so dass mit dem schlimmsten
im spital
und ja es hat einfach nicht funktioniert
und jetzt stellt mehrere bergauf die
intensive und erhalten im bett und das
ist eigentlich bin somit der schlimmsten
sinne also mit
was trägt die shortlist stehen wo nehmen
einfach univision kämpfer und ich würde
gewalt der therapie wenn er immer wieder
stehen aufwändig sie ist und seit ich
bin kunstturnern ich schaff das nicht
möglich
immer wieder neue rück fallen
euro gefallen und bitterböser gemacht
hat jetzt mit energie tanken
er erwarte dank reichenow lange
vollbäder weg du bist langsam mache im
alltag wieder
[Musik]
stück für stück zurück es ist noch ein
weiter weg bis therapie definitiv
abgeschlossen ist eine geduldsprobe für
alle auf den großen wie andere sind
sowie maxi aber die für die taxi noch
nie zu viel macht dann schon eigentlich
traurig
[Musik]
das wäre all das wieder spiele
denn die jetzt lebe so wie sie hoffen
darf dass wir wieder zu entwerten ersten
cd brenner will gelb dass beide jungs
gute sache als zehnter
[Musik]
nützlinge am wurde sie den schein 30
inzwischen wieder alles unter momente
wie sie nie 233 und sind ehemalige
fußball drehen oder buch beschreiben
denken immer viel azeti spiel so schnell
wie möglich fertig ist und nicht so eine
sache druck gemacht was passiert das
einfach gemacht und den fußballtrainer
bohren ist erscheint die letzte zwar
jede woche besucher selber krank erkannt
und diesen damit umgang gewährt zum
beispiel den kopf über andere einfach
tore und vorwärtsgang
so eine scheiße station erlebt
da ich rausgegangen die möglichkeit gibt
es für ihn wohl trotz demokraten dazu
zwei jahre 52 762 dimension
der schein hat ein themenblock noch
andere k und für jede geschafft die
therapie schritt gibt es belohnungen und
jedes kind halt so ein
und das bedeutet demokratie wo man mit
remo mit dem blog angefangen denn die
zum englisch perle wo zum beispiel
videos wie eine tablette und denn ich
bin sehr schwierig medikamenten krämer
puro und hoffnung ein
die pflegende und ärzte unterstützen
familien auf ihrem weg wir zeigen die
ältere - kettensäge gute nachrichten
schlechte nachricht ehrlich ein echter
zehner chöre statistik also wer vier
prozent chance dass man überlebt
da nicht so gern ich bin sicher dass
mich aber prinzipiell sage das 4 5 in
werden teilt der kinderonkologie welt
mit derstandard at finden aber der 5
es gibt momente auf der station wo nur
schweizer dreiecke sind angst warum
schlimmstmögliche begleitet alle darum
sind die schöne unbeschwerte augenblick
besonders hoch
der schein hat wieder ein fenster ihres
pakets für für die route moment nicht
viel führer plan oder dem radio
astrophysical den bundesvorsitz
unglaublich ab nach hause
das ist jetzt zwei jahre her und glich
ich bin der familie brandt gott der in
riga zieht im spital frisch es war wie
in einem film gewesen
nur bei diesem fall ist das ganze für
areale ganz ganz schwierige zeit
wohin die kraft gefunden während das
mieten angeschafft und sind da
eigentlich erforschen und vor dem langen
weg was vielleicht gott weiß wenn dieser
kommt es statt drei gehen immer sehr
sehr sehr sehr viel geht
es war mühsam aber vor allem an bord das
entscheiden und den head allawi nach
positiv denkt und so alle halten immer
noch voraus gleichen moment lebt und so
ist im gange hall tag für tag und
wahrscheinlich wirklich stark wie maxi
und hätte auch sehr sehr viel mitgemacht
wie man also eröffnet verwüstete stadt
anting machen halt dass er hat ein krimi
caveau den verhältnissen gut die
prognosen aus alberschwende zurückfällt
beruhigen dass ältere oder bleibt die
unsicherheit
ich will es anders nicht denken aber er
weiß dass es kann wieder das rädern
einer obama sich erst nach 35 jahre ich
das sagt man das jetzt wirklich vorbei
ist weiß ich immer noch sei ja vorbei
jetzt ist offenbar das ist auch in
dieser löste wie gesagt man positiv
denken gar nicht denken
vielleicht muss einander setzte mit
wachs oder war nach unten wo viel licht
[Musik]
da macht eine chance
diagnose krebs wie die familie wo es
trifft ist ein alptraum
es ist anfang von mein kampf gegen
unberechenbarer gegner
[Musik]
so auf ihrem matthias in die familie und
ich vor zwei jahren im kinderspital
keine klienten kurz vorher erfahren dass
der angeblich der gläubiger zu schaffen
um die rolle spielen zu mir gesagt da
müssen später ordnung
mattia ich noch ganz am anfang stand
etwas im kampf gegen krankheit der
großteil von der chemie ist noch und
schon die erste hätten recht mit
musikalischen
[Musik]
so schwierig nicht so wichtig als
familie im ausnahmezustand stück
normalität erleben und auch im größten
sturm immer wieder schön im moment mit
den antrag
[Musik]
während besucher übernachten infekt über
und hat am morgen eine schöne rede
[Musik]
überhaupt nicht
aber ich damals gemacht
wenn wir so gern richtig helfen
aber alles wurde wieder bis ganz mieses
es gibt jetzt mittag
[Musik]
erholen sondern
mit der durchfahrt
[Musik]
gut zwei jahre später trifft automatisch
zum glück wieder die haie im dorf die
frauen seien
wenn ich direkt das anders wir haben
eigentlich nicht beschweren
wirklich stress aber so sicher eine gute
strecke
diese aber das ist super also wenn das
im moment das problem ist schulstress
heißt da heißt dass es gesundheitlich
ein problem gibt wie die monatliche
kontrolle aber es ist eigentlich die
letzten zwei jahre sind für die ganze
familie schwierig sie sechs jahrzehnte
schweißt am markt ja sich schwester
dahinter husak führt älteren sich mit
schaffen ins spital abgewechselt
der markt hat sich im schnellzugstempo
docomo kämpft er hat sogar und blog
können so gut sie angeschlagen
jetzt ist mark ca 14 und bleibt wieder
das ganze anders laufen aus dem spiel
aber es ist immer möglich das
lieblingsessen
[Musik]
danke für die beiden sind eher selten
die gravierende ägypter geisterhand
gelenkt
was wir jetzt miteinander und auch
richtig dass ich mit nadel süd so
unbeschwert konzerne sie ist eine große
freud wird erst hinter matti nur die
prognose gestellt
ja die erste chance und griff der
überlebenschancen zaubert wusste am
anfang und darf deshalb ganze seltener
kriminell und erhalten so wenig
vergleichswert und intellektuelle seit
er weg war es gibt ja irgendwas prozent
zahlen
wo man sich gar nicht wie das
entwicklerkit der verlauf sich als auch
unterschiedliche und teilweise wagen und
komisch wirken als schwierig sie wäre
und die nächste kontrolle
wie reagiert das widerrufsrecht auf
klima und dann ist immer das auf und ab
der gefühle eigentlich eine ganz
schwierige thema blieben dass überhaupt
etwas studiert gedanken gemacht darüber
übers sterben oder eindrücke alle
übergangen werde mit genannt doch also
haben wir schon gedanken gemacht apple
zum beispiel auch seiten ins spital st
gallen kann ich mir den eben auch denkt
und kann es auch zum pixel ich wenn ich
sterbe ich kann noch so viel vor allem
leben
und ja das habe ich mir ein spital
teilweise über leitzins mal wirklich
schlecht gegangen ich eigentlich geld
jetzt handelt sieht dass ich jetzt auch
mit 13 schon weg bin und ja kann ich mir
den schuh teil ist gedanken gemacht und
da ist das auch mit mami und papi
diskutiert oder ich lebe nicht wählen
dass sie sich sorgen machen
[Musik]
diskussion kam wenig die häftlinge
wählen
diese waren wieder drei aktien jetzt mal
mich seid ja welche mit stolpe sterbe
oder was ich will ich halte medikament
buchhandel und das ist schlechter
hygiene werden und den schon mal darum
gegangen ja ja die situation mag ich
auch noch ganz gut gelaufen ich bin das
kind kann
es gibt eigentlich hinter anderes übrig
macht ja entweder musicstar oder die
andere variante nicht einfach und so
jetzt nicht denn dort jüngst hat zum
segel austin in den stiefvater erkranken
und deshalb mehr als nur kaschiert herz
vor ich weiß noch geld also mir noch
mitte april hat wie verrückt über den
ich den stoff schon der krankheit und
den habe ich mir so denkt sony ihre
krankheit 1000 an dem ich werde wieder
gesund dafür ziehen wo anne war das
älteste bringen jetzt zuerst mal
vorfinden und den hochbau auch noch
erst noch fünf jahre ohne rückfall weiß
behandelt wirklich erfolgreich
das ist allen bewusst aber der marke
anziehen familie zuversichtliche zukunft
und gemüse zieht mit einer sturen dorf
unterhaltung vom turnverein und
automatisch wieder voll mit
[Applaus]
[Musik]
am anfang ist um schwierig sie
vereinfacht erklärt er
wir müssen da wachsen berichtet rektorin
und dieser name ist er trainer
abgesprochen koalition nicht mit der
wirklichkeit zusammen system musik
maßnahmen wirken sie mit schreiben burda
style design in alabama
sein stück für eine machen die muskeln
sind wieder da darf zeigt sich kurz
nachher
[Musik]
ist grossartig
[Applaus]
[Musik]
allez allez
dies beruht
der markt ja bescheid befinden und ihre
familie sind auf dem weg zurück in die
normalität
ich wünsche ihnen allen ein junges beste
auch im umgang mit der ungewissheit und
teil vom leben bleibt
[Musik]